in the new political landscape there was
much in Scottish politics who was turned
on its head
there was the resurgent Tory vote 12
Scottish seats shoring up a troubled
party down south and there was Scottish
independence the issue that turned on
its axis overnight
Alec salmon was a high-profile casualty
of a voters reaction against the second
referendum so to another SNP big hitter
deputy leader
Angus Robertson their party leader at
lay down referendum plans only weeks ago
Nicola Sturgeon acknowledged it had been
a factor in the loss of 21 seats has
scheana lost all prospect of
independence with it look I accept the
independence and an independence
referendum was a factor we cannot escape
the the presence of the constitutional
question in Scottish politics even if we
wanted to so that I think is is the case
and I also have said in response to
others I think there were other factors
at play in the election yesterday as
well and we will take time to consider
them fully Scottish we were one up from
one to seven seats and the Liberal
Democrats from one to four in Scotland
like the Conservatives both benefited
from anti independent sentiment and also
the idea of a referendum should be taken
off the table
the Scottish Conservative leader had
soft advice on brexit to for her own UK
party leader exercising new phone muscle
in shaping a wounded party post-election
at the same time we must in mind see to
deliver an open brexit not a close one
which boosts our country's economic
growth first I am confident the once the
dust settles and last night's results we
can rise to that challenge Nicola
Sturgeon has said she will have more to
say in due course on matters
independence and referendum the wider
independence movement which is rallied
behind her and her SNP party will want
to hear that it remains on the agenda
which should will and the SNP did win
more seats in Scott
well there's little encouragement for
them in the percentage shares of the
vote
support for unionist parties combined
far outstrips backing for the
independence my day in winning an
election Scotland's biggest party might
have suffered its biggest defeat James
Matthews Sky News
Edberg